alors que le gouvernement du québec a
clairement signifié son intention de
faire une place aux plus petites fermes
diversifier la réglementation des fois
toujours adaptés à leur réalité
dernière exemple en lice les eaux
d'incubation un règlement déposée par
les éleveurs industriels propose
d'encadrer et de limiter les activités
des élevages artisanaux ce qui suscite
la colère les petits producteurs
cet oeuf malgré sa fragilité fait vivre
une importante industrie agricole et de
petits producteurs artisans
c'est un oeuf d'incubation
ce poussins deviendra un poulet de chair
une poule pondeuse ou un oiseau destinés
à la reproduction
à peine sorti de sa coquille il se
retrouve malgré lui au coeur d'un
conflit opposant deux visions aux
antipodes de l'agriculture au québec une
confrontation entre les petits
producteurs artisans et aux géants de
l'industrie les producteurs 2
d'incubation du québec les poliques ue
ce qu'on dit c'est que aucune personne
fois fait d une incubation sauf ceux qui
possèdent un quota on tente de nous
mettre des bâtons dans les roues ou
sinon de nous avaler le litige sera
tranchée devant la régie des marchés
agricoles et alimentaires du québec et
la décision pourrait sonner le glas de
plusieurs petites fermes artisanale
au québec l'industrie de la volaille est
fragmenté une quarantaine de producteurs
se spécialise uniquement dans la
production 2 d'incubation à partir de
deux lignées de poule importé des états
unis les races et les cob ils livrent
chaque année plus de 230 millions 2 à
une poignée de grands pouvoirs ou les
oeufs sont un cube et puis les poussins
sont transférés dans des fermes
commerciales pour produire du poulet de
chair ou de la poule pondeuse
[Musique]
parallèlement il y a aussi plusieurs
dizaines de petits producteurs artisans
dans la province il élève des poules de
race très variés rustique patrimonial ou
menacés comme des coucous de malines d
europe et une perdrix et la vendent
ces petits éleveurs assurent eux-mêmes
la reproduction des volailles et font de
la vente directe 2 d'incubation de
poussins et de volaille
on est pas une du tout en compétition
avec les grands élevages industriels
ce qu'on fait c'est complètement
parallèle on est vraiment dans la
préservation des races
avec sa famille marlène bonneville a mis
sur pied en 2016 une petite entreprise
d'élevage de volailles
marlins des microbiologistes et attache
une grande importance à la biodiversité
et à la préservation des races et
l'élève une douzaine de variétés
d'oiseaux moi ce qui me passe un drop en
plus
la génétique des couleurs donc c'est ce
qui m'a vraiment intéressé à me lancer
dans les points ces enfants l'aide à
préparer la saison de reproduction qui
s'étend de février à juin
alizée récolte les oeufs dans les cages
puis son frère n'a kiel les places
soigneusement dans l'incubateur
la productrice vend des oeufs fécondés
et des volailles à des propriétaires de
petites fermes et à des clients qui ont
des poulailler urbain ou qui vise
l'autosuffisance alimentaire
l élève aussi des variétés pour la
sélection et la reproduction
mais sans le savoir marlène travaillent
dans l'illégalité
car depuis 40 ans tout producteur de
l'incubation gros ou petit doit
obligatoirement détenir un quota une
sorte de droit de produire
les poétiques administre le mécanisme
qui régule la production et sa mise en
marché c'est ce qu'on appelle un plan
conjoint il vise toute personne qui
produit un oeuf d'incubation que ce soit
pour ses besoins personnels ou poire la
vente un outil conçu pour répondre aux
besoins de l'industrie avicole le plan
conjoint il doit se limiter à l'oeuvre
d'incubation pour fournir l'industrie et
un marché vraiment spécifique avec des
acteurs très clair
les petits éleveurs quant à eux ont
toujours produit sans quotas mais
aujourd'hui les poules rustique et
patrimoniale gagnent en popularité
d'ailleurs le président dépôts et
gyslain loyer dire recevoir des appels
de personnes intéressées à se lancer
dans la production à petite échelle
alors en eau 2021 la fédération a
demandé à la régie des marchés agricoles
et alimentaires du québec l'autorisation
de modifier son règlement pour
régulariser le statut des producteurs
artisans donc nous on a 10 ans voient
enfin leur sorte que ceux qui nous ont
appelés on voit on va faire en sorte que
l'on veut on voit le donné la permission
en modifiant d'auteuil de la main
le nouveau règlement stipule que
désormais nul ne peut détenir plus de
quinze poules reproductrices et cinq
coques sans quotas la production
annuelle de d'incubation est limité à
les pots et permettent aussi à cinq
producteurs de détenir des quotas ils
pourront ainsi élevé 150 poule et
quarante cinq coques de race rustique et
produire des oeufs d'incubation à des
fins commerciales
la nouvelle à l'effet d'une bombe chez
les producteurs artisans la loi jamais
été appliquée donc c'est à eux il
faudrait demander pourquoi depuis 40 ans
pearson s'est jamais fait taper sur les
doigts alors que l'offre d'occupation en
théorie leur appartient dominique la
montagne sonne l'alarmé auprès des
autres producteurs avec sa conjointe et
les propriétaires d'une petite ferme
familiale à sainte lucie des laurentides
deux chèvres laitières une cinquantaine
de poules métissée et quelques coqs et
pour renouveler son troupeau il un cube
saison
selon lui la proposition dépôt hic est
injustifié car elle limite la
reproduction à la ferme et porte
atteinte au concept de l'autonomie
alimentaire donc moi de me faire dire
que je causais possiblement un préjudice
sérieux à des gens qui produisent 5 6
millions 2 par année alors que moi j'en
produis quelques milliers des gens qui
élève un million quatre cent mille paul
en moyenne alors que moi j'en élèves
moins de 99 je trouvais que c'était à
bérat de nous mettre dans le même panier
dominique la montagne déplore par dessus
tout le geste unilatéral dépôt hic on
absolument a pas été consultés peut-être
qu'ils nous connaissent pas par notre
nom mais ils savent pertinemment qu'un
mouvement artisanale une agriculture
artisanale qui essayent de d'émerger de
ce cartel là une centaine de petits
éleveurs demande à la régie des marchés
agricoles et alimentaires
d'annuler le règlement est d'être exclus
du plan conjoint le nombre élevé de
producteurs artisans a surpris les
politiques mais honnêtement nous on ne
savait pas qui en avait autant pour ceux
qui paient nos affaires puis on continue
comme ça c'est tout le temps comme ce
qu'on fait depuis leur offre depuis que
je suis là et la venue du new règlement
à faire en sorte que l'on a vu qu'avec
plus quoi penser moi je pense que quand
on veut changer quelque chose il faut
toujours se poser la question de savoir
comment on le fait avec les gens et pas
contre les gens forcément
le professeur patrick müller s'intéresse
au développement rural et à la
production sans quotas il croit que la
grogne des petits producteurs est tout à
fait légitime je la comprends parce
qu'il se sent tout d'un coup
réglementée par des gens qui ne sont
dont il ne pense pas qu'il les
représente au fond on a d'affaires à
deux logiques on a deux mondes qui ce
qu'ils se parlent pas beaucoup un four
connaître
le principal argument évoqué par les
producteurs 2 d'incubation du québec
pour changer le règlement c'est l'enjeu
de la bio sécurité quand je les entends
dire toujours là mieux sécurité je pense
toujours à ceux à ce proverbe qui dit si
tu veut tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la
rage mais selon le président les peaux
hic le risque de transmission de
maladies des petits élevages vers les
grands airs et elles peuvent oser que ça
existe c'est celle au québec ça faisait
ça nantes à lyon ça existe partout le
vétérinaire jean pierre vaillancourt est
plus nuancé ce spécialiste de la bio
sécurité et du contrôle des maladies
infectueuses a été invité par la
fédération a témoigné aux audiences de
la régie
il classe les élevages en trois
catégories les grands sites de
production industrielle
les fermes artisanale qui vendent des
oeufs d'incubation et des oiseaux et les
basses-cours qui ne font pas de commerce
on sait que les basco ne représente pas
un risque important c'est des réservoirs
de réservoir de pathogènes mais c'est
pas eux qui contaminent des élevages
commerciaux dans le cas des petites
firmes commerciales tant au québec qu'au
canada aucune étude scientifique ne
permet de conclure qu'elles transmettent
des pathogènes dans les gros élevages
la vigilance s'impose tout de même selon
lui surtout son parc d'élevage
alternatif qui fait de la reproduction
ça veut dire à ce moment là que les
oiseaux vont naître sur six est le
suivant lier alors littéralement vous
pouvez avoir des oiseaux produits dans
ces petits élevages là qui sont des
chevaux de troie
parce que les facteurs de risque
principaux c'est pas tellement le nombre
d'oiseaux c'est comment légère comment
se promènent comment on partage ces
animaux-là son équipement
[Applaudissements]
mais les problèmes de contamination
peuvent aussi provenir des gros élevages
industriels
et d'ailleurs ça s'est vu ce la
production dite industrielle les
éleveurs qu'on a au québec leur
production se fait avec un certain
risque on le voit en nouvelle écosse
avec l'influenza aviaire hautement
pathogène là qui frappe dans un élevage
donc ça va dans les deux sens
jean pierre vaillancourt croit que
malgré leurs différents petits et grands
producteurs ont intérêt à dialoguer car
la multiplication éventuelle des
élevages artisanaux et une plus grande
proximité des sites de production
pourraient un jour s'avérer lourde de
conséquences pour tous les éleveurs y en
a combien les élevages au québec
présentement personne ne sait son centre
trouve avec 5 c'est ce petit élevage en
date d'un kilomètre d'un troupeau de
reproduction au québec éventuellement
savoir comment zerbo québécois nous
prêtait d'en face
dans l'espoir de calmer le jeu la
fédération vient de déposer une nouvelle
mouture de son règlement ça va être un
projet qui va être structures là qui
vont être
accueillis j'espère positivement par la
plupart des jeunes un éleveur qui
produit 1000e d'incubation par année
mais n'en fait pas le commerce
pourraient produire sans quotas il
serait aussi possible de produire et
mettre en marché jusqu'à 6000 e
d'incubation par année en étant exemptés
du plan conjoint mais à la condition que
ces éleveurs déclare le nombre d'eux
d'incubation produits mis en marché est
incubé à la ferme et qu'ils suivent une
formation sur la biosécurité la
salubrité et le bien-être animal payé
par la fédération
les éleveurs artisans oppose une fin de
non recevoir cette nouvelle proposition
ce port la responsabilité des pays aux
écus de se mêler du bien être animal et
des normes de biosécurité ou d'essayer
de venir contrôler ce qui se passe dans
les petits élevages c'est vraiment au
mapaq de s'occuper d'autres c'est la
régie des marchés agricoles et
alimentaires du québec qui aura le
dernier mot on arrêtera pas de faire ce
qu'on fait si les politiques décident de
2,2 mettra en marche de mep d'appliquer
le règlement puis de nous de nous mettre
en contravention mais on va reprendre la
bataille à partir de ce moment là
marlène bonneville appréhende le pire
pour elle et d'autres éleveurs on sera
pas capable de rester dans l'inégalité
il va falloir se départir lancement de
nos oazo mais de tout le travail qui a
été investi dans ces oiseaux
pour dominique la montagne le terroir
doit pouvoir s'exprimer librement
l'avenir de l'autonomie alimentaire et
du développement des régions est en jeu
pour moi un circuit court que ça c'est
un circuit court où on va reproduire
élevé à battre transformer et vendre à
la ferme parce qu'on peut nourrir des
gens pour de vrai dans la communauté
qu'on habite on a des consommateurs qui
aujourd'hui demandent ceinture là aussi
une nouvelle génération d'agriculteurs
qui a envie de faire les choses
autrement d'être de faire de la
production plus diversifiée
il faut pouvoir goûter aux aliments qui
sont enracinés dans des lieux
particuliers pour pouvoir dire qui est
allé manger seule la solo telle région
c'est le fun aller goûter ça c'est ça
qui va aider l'agrotourisme à être autre
chose qu'une promenade en machine le
dimanche